we have a beautiful guest today stavos
I've I've been a fan of his for a very
long time he's done bad friends before
um and um I've been watching him from
afar he's um really just he's like a Tim
Dylan in my opinion a guy that can go
anywhere into space and go into spaces
that I can't even get to you know but um
it's very exciting um oh yeah I know
what space he got into that you didn't
what I think it was like a really like
was a fashion show in like
par who Tim Dylan no um stavi yeah yeah
oh yeah I remember that I remember you
being real like oh about [__] mad
about that [__] Andrew was in it too
right everyone was I think Theo was yeah
yeah why were they there I think they
needed what hi what's up guys yeah
what's up how you doing good what's this
about what do you mean he's talking
about how angry he was that he wasn't
invited to that fashion show you did and
yeah was that your thing it wasn't my
thing but did you mention my name or no
no man who else was in it who else was
in it Santino I know dude you know him
yeah yeah yeah who else uh who else Mato
yeah wasn't Theo in it too Theo yeah
yeah the good the best guys yeah good
guys yeah yeah yeah cuz I wasn't invit
I'm not one of the best guys no I think
it's more that you have kind of like a
like a child's body and it was like a
Men's Wear line you know he doesn't
really make like toddlers clothes yeah
yeah but I mean but they
had special let me just ask you
something dude since the last time I saw
you did you eat somebody I've gotten I
have gotten fatter yes yeah what
happened too many Heroes yeah look it's
not my fault you didn't get on this
[__] you don't have to treat me like
this out of the gate I know you just
said a baby's body you do have a bab
right you get a little wi that's it it's
I'm not trying to be mean
I think you're great thanks man yeah
yeah cuz you know what what guys let me
just say something you're people cuz you
have a little tan I do it just looks
good that way I hit I hit the I hit the
uh uh pool before coming here did you
really yeah you don't live here 80° no
you live where I live in New York in New
York City mhm in the uh in what part I
live in Queens [__] yeah D does this
feel like really warm weather to you
absolutely it seems incredible I've
never been colder really this is cold
for you it was [__] hot today I come
I came off the plane and it was like you
know it's just like in the little weird
tunnel from the plane to the thing it
was hot as [__] I was I was excited it's
cold as hell and you just got in today I
just got in dude I'm off the Jet right
to you whoa dog how long you in town for
um four or five days I'm doing the last
part I'm actually you're the bookend
Bobby I start here and I end with bad
friends on satday I never I was I never
got that approval I'm wa am I not
approved I may not do it now come on you
you came here with hot dude you came no
I I came in nice no you no you came in
smiling you s out a baby's body no after
you got mad at me for something I was
just oh yeah you're right no but she's
the cuz I was just complaining okay and
then she's the one that well he said
that you get invited into spaces he
can't reach or get to and I was like oh
like the fashion show he was like oh
[__] the fashion show if I was being
mean I would say like the top shelf but
I'm not going to do
that
okay okay I didn't do it all right all
right I always say something right but
medium sh also but in that group with
the fashion let's let go of the Fashion
Group right but like I want to talk
about for a second right my thing is is
that um what I'm asking you is that when
you were with those guys doing the
fashion show did you look around go yeah
this is the
elite um not really cuz what I thought
was these are the people one guy is into
cuz it was all like kid super you know
what I mean who kid super the guy the
designer who kid super col he's a cool
dude but it felt like he just kind of
you're gonna have to take it up with him
man you're right you know show thank you
you know who's modeling my petite line
who I yeah wait that'd be actually
that's a really good idea to have like a
me and trailer trash Tammy no like a a
short King petite Men's Wear line I love
it bro I love it dude well here's what I
I I probably shouldn't give this away
but I want to do a I want to do a
tracksuit line that starts at XL it's
only for fat people can not get it if
you're not fat really it starts at XL go
to like 8X yeah you're but I'm not can I
just say something that's not you I'm
just saying oh yeah yeah yeah because I
want to wear types of our b i me I'll
make one special for you no can we just
do an on
EXs or a fat asian a fat asian line
you're right right so it's like in Asia
XS fat what is it fat small small yeah
yeah yeah anyway but I think that um
stavi has the look you're so you guys
have similar Styles right you do the
Aloha shirt but I think what you're
missing is the jewelry the gold I think
that you should start wearing jewelry
you want to go jewelry shopping do you
have a guy I in New York yeah I do
somebody who helped
meel I have one thing I I have to say
please
no why why don't you wear jewelry
because every it makes my neck Rin
that's fake you're getting fake
jewelry come on dude is that what it no
really yes you've had money for 30 what
do you mean that's fake jewelry it turns
it
green yeah you're getting SC what you no
honestly what are you talking about
that's like some kind of oxidization
[__] is happening yeah I wear jewelry